thank you very much so hello everyone
I'm very happy to be here with you all
and in this talk we see together how to
build web maps from scratch using jungle
if you're asking yourself what type of
maps we can build with Django let's see
an example
this map show mountain peaks all around
the world
we all use map like this every day in
web or mobile application and I bid that
one specifically with Django and
postgres in this talk we'll see together
how to build a map like that but first I
present a bit myself
as I said I'm Paulo Mercure and I'm a
city of the 20 tab
I'm a software engineer and long time
python back-end developer after using
Django for a few years I became a
contributor to the project
and I also really like hiking in the
mountains in Italy we have a lot of them
so in this talk I decided to build with
you a map where I can put all mountain
peaks I've reached
I took this photo from the starting
point on one of my last hike
I was in the Italian and penins and the
sun is not yet risen but in the distance
there is the Adriatic Sea
the making of this map will be a bit
like this like we'll start from his
scratch and then we'll go up in attitude
but let's start from the basic about web
Maps
however map
have many features it can be static
Dynamic you can interact with it or you
can only view hits the map can use
raster or vector tiles to represent the
surface usually the data is stored in a
special database
and the web map we use a JavaScript
library to show data on your map
on Wikipedia reading
regarding web Maps we can read that web
web mapping is the process of using web
Maps delivered by geographic information
system on the internet
but
implementing a geographic information
system from scratch is beyond the scope
of this tool so to do this as you can
imagine we are going to use Django my
preferred python based web framework
the requirements to create our map with
Django are as stable and supported
version of Python and the latest stable
version of Django itself
in my example I've installed all of it
in a virtual environment
to create the map project our project I
switched to my project directory and
then use the start project Django
command and the basic files of our
project will be created for us
after switching in the new created my
map directory we create our markers app
with the Django startup command again
all the necessary file will be created
for us
now we have to activate our markers
application by inserting its name in the
list of installed apps
in our setting file
at this point we can proceed to insert
in the markers view file a new template
View for the page of our map
simple one
in the markers templates directory we
can now create a template file for our
map for now we had only usual boarding
plates with a title but without any body
content
and in the marker URL file we must now
add the path
to the view over map using its template
View
as a last step we include in turn the
URL file of the marker app in that of
the project
we just made a first view in Django but
it will only show a blank page for now
so we can move on something more
challenging
I took this other photo after half an
hour or walking in the dark
and you can see this the sunrise in the
distance and we are about to start the
High Altitude path as for our hike
something will be to be seen in our
project as well in fact we'll add a
blank map page
using the leaflet Library
leaflet is one of the most used
JavaScript libraries for web Maps it's a
free software and it's desktop and
mobile friendly and it's very light and
it has a very good documentation that
you can read directly online
to use leaflet we need to link in the
head of the page it's JavaScript and CSS
module in our template
in addition using the jungle static
template tag we'll also link our custom
CSS file
in the body we need also a dfv tag with
a specific ID and our custom Javascript
file
which we are going to create now
we add our CSL file in the static
directory and inside it we only had
the basic rule to show a full screen map
and now in our Javascript file we add
the code to view our map
using the defined variables we
initialize an open street map layer we
hook the newly defined layer to our map
and in the last segment set the map view
that mostly contain the word with the
maximum zoom level possible
that's it
we can now start our jungle project with
the Run server command and we can
finally visit our map page in the
browser
so we just created an empty map with
Django and the result is pretty much
what you see now a map without markers
showing the whole world
these photos show a Crossroads at the
end of the first part of my hike just
before a very challenging uphill stretch
this is another reason for a while and
Landscape is visible around
likewise having a visualized our map
with leaflet we'll now start a bit more
elaborate part writing more chord to
create our markers and this display them
so it's time to get to know and activate
geojango the geographic the Django
Geographic module
Django added Geographic function a few
years ago in the JS module with specific
Fields database backhands special
queries and also admin integration
since then many new useful features have
been added every year until the latest
version
before activating it we need to install
some requirements
a mandatory geojango requirement is GD
hey hell it's a Osgo Libre library for
reading and writing roster and Vector
special data formats and it has a very
or useful command for data translation
and processing
to easily install gdhil package on
antabium-based system you can use update
package manager
in this simple way
and we can Now activate the geodango by
adding the contrib JS module to the
installed apps in our project settings
but to use geojango correctly we need to
change also our database engine and use
one of the con compatible database
backend in this talk for a more more
complex example we decided to start
using specialized the specialized
tension to sqlite which is the default
Django database backend
it provides Vector geodatabase
functionality and it's released with a
free software license
it is a simple architecture a complete
the base in an ordinary file that's it
as before
on Debian based system we can install
the special light package using the APT
package manager in that way
and now we let's hard specializes at the
big weekend in the setting default
engine and in our project we leave the
rest of our code and change it we only
have to change the engine
definition
so now we can we have everything to
Define our marker model to store a
location and a name
um our two fields are both mandatory the
location is a simple point field and
we'll use the name to represent the
model
we can now generate a new database
migration and then apply it to our
database using this this command
to easily insert new markers in the map
we use the Django admin interface
we Define a marker admin class by
inheriting the gis model admin class
which uses the openstreetmap layer in
its widget and we'll see in a bit
we can now create a super user to access
our admin interface and after starting
the project locally and finally we can
start our Django project with run server
command and visit our admin section in
the browser
and at the end
here here is the page for inserting the
markers in our admin
as you can see
we have a text field to enter the name
of the location and GIS widget
we have to manually navigate the map and
manually Define the point in in the
space
but it work it's
ready to use
okay after having added more of that
markers in the admin we can finally show
them in our map
we can do that by adding the information
in our view
here we are retrieving all the markers
from the database and converting them to
jio Json before adding them to the
contest context of our view
the value of the markers key in the
context dictionary will be something
like that geojson standard Geo Json
document in this case only one point
okay now in our template we use the GEOS
the Json script a template tag to add
our markers to our page in a secure way
and
now let's set it to our Javascript file
and store the geojson in a variable
starting from this variable we built a
layer for our map and we extract also
the name of the single marker
finally we add the layer in our map by
setting the view to contain all the data
so all the points in the map
we can finally start again our project
with the Run server command and see our
marker in our map
in in this URL
okay
in this map we see a few marker I
uploaded through the admin they are
inside the pitch code but
the loading is still fluid and fast
you can also see the pop-up in the
marker of the peak I'm heading toward
the in the cycle
but if you add a lot more marker to show
our map loading will be much slower and
leaflet will have a harder time
rendering all of them so we need a
better more complex solution here
these photos show a beautiful landscape
that came to my site at the end of a
challenging claim the itis Peak begin to
be seen But there are still challenging
passages before reaching the summit of
our hike so we then continue
implementing the final version of our
map
to do that first let's start using
post.js as a new backhand engine
JS is a postgres extension and it's also
the best database backend for geojango
it internally integrates special data
and as a special data types indexes and
functions
in this chart I've synthesized the
compatibility table of the open source
geography backend supported by geojango
in the geojango documentation there are
three of this table as you can see the
post.js is the only Geographic backhands
that support 100
or the feature so it's a better choice
for us
in order to use post GIS as a database
backend we need to install the postgres
C client Library
as before you can do it easily with appd
package manager
the python requirements of our
approaching project are increasing and
therefore is a good practice to create a
requirement file with the package list
in addition to Django we are going to
use psycho PG Django filter jungle rest
framework and its Geographic addon
we install all the python requirements
using the python package installer
module
we modify the project database settings
adding the post.js engine and the
connection parameters of our project
uh for our database possible database
which you can have locally or remotely
or in Docker whatever
we have now to apply again all the
immigration to the new configured
postgres database
and the package that we'll use directly
in the code of our project are Django
rest framework and its Geographic addon
which we then insert in the list of the
style adapts of our project settings
so let's create a serializer for our
marker class
in everything from rest framework.js
serializer we only have to define the
optional field to be shown in the
additional properties the geographic
field location and the model marker
Our intention is to expose our market
via a restful API and to do so with the
final read-only views it
we set the location as a field to filter
our markers and then a filter based on a
bound box we also return all markers
instance without any filter
in the market application we Define the
URL of our new endpoint using the jungle
rest framework default router to create
our path
and finally we had to the definition of
the URL of our project A New Path
for the API that includes the path just
specified for our marker up
so after finishing our restful API we
move on to update our Javascript file
as we no longer have the data preloaded
in our page we no longer have a way to
position the map so that it contains all
the markers
so we try to look at user through the
browser that will ask them to share
their location if in the positive case
we'll use the shared location to Center
the map and that's it in the native case
we locate them on an arbitrary point on
the map with a low zoom level
so we no longer load the marker directly
on the page and
so we ask our endpoint to return only
marker on the specific displayed area
passed as a bounded box string as you
can see on the URL
to build the marker layer we ask our
endpoint the data for data
asynchronously and extract the
properties we want to show in the
pop-ups
we we invoke this flow every time the
users stop moving on the map
not every second so in this way our
query will be retrieved only a minimum
number of data from the database and the
response to the browser will be layer
and faster to render for leaflet
okay finally here is our complete map
index example we can see how Market
specific map Outlook
but let's small let's do a small demo of
how dynamically the map wrote
if it were
okay
the loading takes place in very full way
because the number of calls occurs only
when the movement of the map stop and
therefore the data traffic is reduced to
the essential
as well as the rendering of the marker
carried out by leflats
okay
okay our map project as our map or
project the hike also reached its final
destination and unfortunately the
viewing is what is a bit covered but we
can finally add a new marker in our map
built with Django it was one of the
longest hike I ever made and I hope to
be able to do new ones soon
but there are also many other features
that can be added in the future in the
map for example marker customization and
pop-ups to show more information
marker filtering based on relational
data
a clustering of the markers bought in
front end and in McCann part or using
geocoding services to add marker
locations starting from an address and
not manually and so on
at the end of the talk before saying
goodbye I want to share with you some
tips based on my experience as a map
developer with Django
the first one is read the documentation
in the jungle website because it's full
information
about the geojango
read also details about geographic
queries in the post.js website because
it helps you to understand how things
work at a lower level
read also the source code of both
project
on GitHub because there is something you
can learn only from the codes
and
I also recommend to search for question
on Stacks exchange by trying to answer
by them them by yourself and on reading
the answer it's a good way to improve
last but not least you can also study
this presentation because it's realistic
Creative Commons license and I'll share
the
Link in a bits
so in 2010 we have developed many maps
with Django you can find more about our
open source project and map project our
protonic Works using this context
and finally to find out more my personal
works with positive yes Django and maps
you can use all my contacts with this QR
code you can download directly this
presentation from my website
so thanks again for me and enjoy the
other talks in the conference
[Applause]
thank you so much Paulo I'm going to
jump into the questions on slido okay so
I have one request if you don't mind if
I can take a picture with you you all
great
okay ready for the questions yeah okay
can we extend the map widget in Django
admin page for example adding stuff like
scale bar map legend and North Arrow
yes we can do that and the widgets in
in the admin
is ready to use but it's built using
another
JavaScript library open layers
it's an historic
choice because it started from Jungle
1.0
it worked very well but you have to
learn another way to do things if you're
using leaflet
for your front-end page but it worked
with with it
some project okay it possible
cool any use case where sqlite with
spatial extension would not be enough
and need to be to use Advanced databases
like post GIS
yeah I used SQL lights
and specialized to have an example if
you have a small maps with few points
you don't need distributed database with
very good performance
it's the best choice you can you can do
but
in the second part I show you how to use
post.js because it's the performance
that are better and also it's more
complete from the point of view or
function expression you can use directly
from your Django so there is some
queries you can can do
uh using only special lights they are
very specific but if you start doing
Maps more and deep maybe you you need
something very specific a certain a
certain point if you need only to show
some points in the map specializes
enough
right
so Christian wants to know do you have
any experience how useful geodango would
be considering map campus Maps or even
building or floor plans
campus Maps yeah so maybe indoor maps
never thought about that what we we are
doing a project with layer
um under the level of the grounds so
layer a different altitude to
ease and geocoding in
is a project that study the the layer of
the terrains and under the under hit so
it's not in in the robot it's different
from the ground exactly
cool another question how can you deploy
the app using Django for 200 around 200
users in a company
to enter the user yeah so how do you I
guess scale the app yeah I don't I don't
think 200 user
accurate number so fair enough so the
the app should be robust to that yes
okay
um are there any other questions in the
room
if not we can
yeah I want to know that too
there was so much uh markers on the maps
that was very impressive to see so yeah
yeah I like traveling and doing some
some hikes but
also when I go abroad I search for is or
lowest points I I put also a
a point in the the twally in U.S it is
lowest point and yes
and yeah I enjoy working with maps and
also going in
physically in the point
I like hiking too so that was a great
personal project I suppose
um great thank you so much Paulo thank
you everyone who participated thank you
very much let's have a good lunch
[Applause]